thanks for joining us on this episode of
Star talk today I've got my one-on-one
conversation with historian Yuval Noah
Harare you know him from his widely read
books homodeus 21 lessons for the 21st
century and other books in this
conversation it ranges widely we talk
about Ai and what role it has played and
will play we talk about what glue holds
together societal institutions not only
of government but of the financial
system how stories that we tell each
other are what we just have to believe
in order for any of this to work in the
first place it's pretty scary stuff just
how tentative and how how balanced on a
pinhead civilization is well this guy is
an expert in it all and we we don't
leave any Stones unturned in this
episode of Star
foreign
[Music]
this is star talk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today we're featuring
a a conversation we do this every now
and then when the when the guest is is
so accomplished and has so much to say
and and is into such interesting subject
matter that we devote the entire episode
to just a one-on-one conversation and
today that's going to be with Professor
Yuval Noah Harari and he is a professor
of history at Hebrew University of
Jerusalem and you may know him as the
author of some hugely best-selling books
sapiens every history of mankind
homodeus A Brief History Of Tomorrow 21
lessons for the 21st century and just
recently a new book called Unstoppable
us
how humans
took over the world that's a kid's book
oh my God Illustrated Kids book for
tweens age eight to twelve looking
forward to that anyhow uh you've all
welcome to start talk oh thank you it's
good to be here
yeah yeah so uh what what made you write
a children's book what what were you fed
up with adults you said let me get to
the let me get to where you know the
Next Generation because I'm giving up on
the adults no it's you know it's kind of
broadening the horizons and basically
um kids want to understand who they are
and there's a historian I think that who
we are is shaped to a large extent by
history
if you start with things like the games
you play so you play basketball or
baseball or football it comes from
somewhere the food that we eat if we eat
if you like to eat chocolate for
instance then you have a bit of Olmec
civilization in you because it was the
olmecs that discovered how to make
chocolate something no mix from Mexico
yeah Mexico something like I don't know
4 000 years ago
um and if you go all the way down to
your basic emotions
um so if you wake up in the middle of
the night afraid of a monster under the
bed this is actually a historical memory
from millions of years ago when humans
lived in the African Savannah and there
were indeed monsters that came to eat
kids in the night if a lion came to eat
you and you woke up and ran away you
survived
so understanding who we are from the
games we play and the food we eat down
to our emotions and feelings this is
really understanding history
well as an historian I mean that's
that's the lens through which you're
observing the world and that's great
because that'll highlight certain
elements of our conduct of our habits
that have uh deep roots that I think we
don't always notice or appreciate so
thanks for making that admission
statement but what do you mean by how
humans uh took over the world what do
you mean by that
but you know we now control this planet
to a large extent uh we control the
future the fate of almost all the other
animals of the the evolution of life
itself the Lions the elephants the
whales they now depend on us and this is
quite strange because if you look at us
individually as an individual I'm not
stronger and not even much smarter than
a chimpanzee or an elephant or the whale
and uh so how did we come to dominate
this this planet to such an extent this
is the big question that interests me as
a historian of course it links with with
other uh uh with other scientific
disciplines you can't really understand
history without understanding biology
and you know biology is built on top of
chemistry and physics so it's all links
together
I'm kind of thinking that you are much
smarter than a chimp in elephant I just
even if it's not true I want to think
that I'm actually sure because you know
if you do a real test not a test like in
school I mean if you give me an elephant
a testing school then obviously I mean
I'll do better but if yeah put me in an
elephant or a chimp or a pig on a
deserted island and we have to survive
for a month or a year find our food get
away from predators whatever this is a
real test I wouldn't place my bets on me
you're going to ask where's the nearest
Quick Mart to get some food
exactly I mean for most of what we need
for our survival today we depend on
other people maybe on the other side of
the world which we don't even know we
don't know how to get our own food how
to get our build our shelters whatever
this is really what makes us so special
that we can cooperate in these large
trade networks and they could not
special wait special or vulnerable right
because I think every not a day goes by
when I see a bird flying high or a
squirrel running under underfoot and I
say to myself they don't need shopping
centers or cars or Supply chains and if
the supply chain goes out and humans
would starve and the squirrels will just
keep keep about their way and the birds
will continue to fly so I I do think
about that often and I think about how
susceptible we may be to societal
collapse absolutely we are very we are
extremely powerful and we are extremely
fragile at one in the same time it does
not contradict each other it often goes
together when you build something really
big and powerful and complicated it's
also very brittle at the same time you
see it also with human societies that
the the the bigger they are the more
susceptible they are to all kinds of
Crisis that don't really threaten a
small hunter-gatherer band
so so what would you say over the years
you know when I think of human history I
think of maybe since agriculture of
course it goes farther back but the part
of our history that where we were
settled and had cities and states and
this sort of thing
um was it one thing that empowered us to
take over the world or was it multiple
things
um
I think it's it's one essential thing
and if you look at all uh the big human
achievements I don't know flying to the
moon for instance yeah yeah that's for
me that's up there yeah okay yeah I mean
I like that one yeah it's all based on
large-scale cooperation how did uh
humans get to the Moon it wasn't Neil
Armstrong by himself flying there
it was millions of people cooperating to
build the spaceships and to do the math
and to provide the food and the special
clothing and everything it's millions
and the funding and the funding and the
funding absolutely yeah I I I try to
soften I mean as much as I love Neil
Armstrong the fact is I try at every
turn to remind people that this was the
work of tens of thousands of scientists
and engineers and an agency and the will
of an assassinated President and a I
mean just add it all up it's you're
you're right on to say that there is no
singular achievement anywhere anything
big anything that big is is a hugely
Cooperative yeah so it's it's true of of
getting to the moon it's true of
building the pyramids it's true of of
all the big achievements of humanity and
then you ask yourself the big question
becomes why are we capable of
cooperating on such a large scale when
chimpanzees or Elephants or pigs can't I
mean if you take a thousand chimpanzees
and cram them together into a bowl or
into a sports Stadium that's a funny
picture just to imagine right
and right right they're not building
anything exactly absolutely right so and
and so this is the really big question
of what makes it possible for us to
cooperate and the answer here at least
my answer is is quite surprising it's
the ability to invent and believe
fictional stories
because underneath every large-scale
cooperation at the bottom you always
find some kind of fictional story not a
scientific truth not necessarily
mathematical calculations but a
fictional story
well maybe if I not to put words in your
mouth but maybe a better word there
would be a bit of Mythology yes that you
want to believe in because I when I
think when people use myth as the
opposite word of truth I think it
undervalues what role's myths have
played historically you know we don't
say well Zeus is false you know that's
not the idea the idea is there are
lessons there in the in the in the myths
that have been handed down over time so
but but go on all right so so what's an
example of a of a myth or a falsehood
that I mean first of all it's not
falsehood it's not it's not a lie it's
not false and I tend not to use the word
myth I prefer fiction because it's not
just religion I mean the obvious example
is of course religion that you get
millions of people to cooperate on a
project could be build a cathedral or a
hospital or go to wager Crusade because
they all believe in the same mythology
but
um it's much broader than that because
our economic system is also based on
fictional entities if you think about
corporations if you think about money
money is not an objective entity money
is not like a black hole or a star that
is is an objective entity that you can
it's not an object it's a it's a concept
really right yeah and uh if you think
about the value of money the value of
money comes from stories that people
tell and believe each other the greatest
story colors in the world are not the
people who win the Nobel Prize in
literature it's the people who win the
Nobel prize in economics they tell the
really powerful Stories the really the
the stories that everybody believes you
know not everybody believes in the same
God or in any God but everybody believes
in money and if you think about it it's
strange because even no other animal
knows even knows that something like
money exists if you give I don't know a
pig you give an apple on in one hand and
a pile of a million dollars in new notes
in the other hand the pig would
obviously choose the Apple
and the chimpanzee the same and the
Elephant besides us nobody knows that
something like money exists so the value
of money doesn't come from the paper I
mean most money in the world today is
not even paper it's just electronic data
moving between computers
and so where is the value from it's from
Stories We believe if you think about
new currencies like cryptocurrencies
like Bitcoin I mean that's a very good
and current example you tell a story
about something and if enough people
believe it it works I mean you and I we
we agree to extract money for what we do
like lectures or books or whatever why I
mean we can't eat the money that people
give us but we believe that if we go to
a supermarket and give this to the
cashier we can get an apple
and why do they why do they agree to
accept the the the money because they
also believe that if they go to a shoe
store and give this money to the
salesperson they will get choose and as
long as everybody believes in the story
it works is this good or bad I mean
you're saying we're at risk of the
belief system collapsing and thereby
taking the entire monetary system with
it are we really ever at risk of that
and isn't money just an a more
convenient form of barter
um first of all yes we are at risk of
the whole thing collapsing it happens
from time to time in history
that I mean in inflation that
everybody's not talking about to some
extent is that that uh uh um the value
of the money is not what we were told it
is
but and inflation can sometimes hit you
know thousands of percents millions of
percents and eventually the money
becomes worthless you have these images
from certain periods in history like in
Germany in the 1920s wheelbarrows of
money people use it I don't know it's
toilet paper because it's lost all its
value
so that that's that's a real Danger and
I actually oriented own a Deutsche Mark
from the Weimar Republic and the number
billion is written out in zeros on it
and I just have it I just stay you know
billion that's we we deal in billions in
astrophysics but not not in buying a
loaf of bread and so it was just I just
stare at it and I say wow this actually
happened yeah I think that in in in 1946
in Hungary they had the worst inflation
ever in history that we know about and
they have their banknotes with
quintillions not not billions oh my gosh
I gotta get one of those okay yes
billions trillions quadrillions
quintillions yeah okay that's that
that's getting up there but but so all
right is it
um do you do you are you do you have a
better idea or do you do you think money
should be replaced by something else not
that has a greater tangibility I'm not
saying it's bad
um and when I said something you just
observe it you're observing this fact
it's just that something that we invent
in order to cooperate better money
enables strangers all over the world to
cooperate with each other again the food
we eat the clothes we get we don't need
to go to the forest to to to to to
collect it and hunt it and gather it we
rely on people on the other side of the
world the big question in the economy is
how do you trust strangers that's the
biggest economic question of all it's
it's trust and money is really just
trust money is not made of gold or paper
or anything money is just trust and it's
the job of bankers and finance ministers
and so forth is to build trust being
between people it's not bad and again to
take it another example you think about
I don't know the laws of football or
basketball people they are also
fictional they don't come from physics
or biology they're not written in our
DNA they are not coming from Heaven
they're arbitrary yeah they are quite
arbitrary and fictional rules that exist
only in our own imagination and there is
nothing bad about it this is what
enables
um people to cooperate in in games with
that analysis which I I don't I don't
see how there's a rational rebuttal to
it although to say it's fictional kind
of makes you feel a little uneasy
because it's uh it creates a worry
factor that wasn't there before you use
that word but but uh is there is there a
way now that you've analyzed it as such
is there a way to move forward and say I
can improve on this or I can add a
little tangibility where there wasn't
before to provide therefore a layer of
stability that previously was ongenta
I think it just becomes less and less
stable as history progresses we are
moving and that's our podcast thank you
no I mean you know history I mean the
pace of change just keeps accelerating
um and the pace of economic change
technological change political change I
mean the good thing about realizing that
something is just fiction is that you
can if it's if it's if it's unfair if
there is a problem you can change it I
mean if you think that the basic laws
governing our society they are not
server laws like the laws of physics or
they are absolute Eternal truth coming
from from God then even if something
seems unfair what can you do these are
just the laws of nature or laws of God
but if you realize no this is just some
inventions that came out of the human
imagination and uh we can improve on
them
so then you get something I don't know
like the U.S Constitution
the U.S Constitution doesn't say it
comes from God God is never mentioned in
the U.S Constitution the laws are not
presented either as it's coming from God
or as reflecting the laws of nature they
are just with the people decided on them
and therefore we can change them and you
have changes luckily over the last 250
years in fact there's a quote from
George Washington where commenting on
the Constitution he says you know I'm
not quite sure if this how this is going
to work but at least there's a there are
Provisions to modify it going forward
and that's the amazing that's I think
that's the the amazing thing about the
U.S Constitution which was very new
because most Societies in history until
that time they claimed that their basic
laws are Eternal unchangeable because
they come from either God or the laws of
nature or the king or a king right I
mean but the key was again why is he
King because God said it should be king
yeah of something that helps out it
helps out when God made your king that's
right yeah
one of the interesting things
you know thinking about physics and
astrophysics but for most of History
astrophysics was very closely linked to
politics
it was the same story the story of the
heavens on the in the stars and the
creation of the universe it was
intimately linked to uh the political
story of why is this guy the king and
gives us all the commands and which was
also a great burden to science because
whenever you tried to change what people
thought about the origins of the
universe for instance it had immediate
political implications right right and
something like the U.S Constitution was
very new because it says no these laws
have nothing to do with astrophysics
they have nothing to do with the
creation of the universe it's just some
law some things we thought about we
thought of these of good laws
that we might be uh ignorant to some
extent that we are not perfect we are
just humans so we also include a
mechanism to amend
these laws and you know now that it's
very common to say a lot of negative
stuff are the founding fathers of the US
and so forth and there are a lot of
things to criticize them about for
instance that they talk about Liberty
but they hold slaves
but the good thing you can say about
them they provided a mechanism for their
descendants to improve on what they did
which is more than you can say about
almost any previous uh uh political
Elite or rulers in human history which
tended to say these laws they are not
our invention they came from somewhere
else and they are never to be changed so
realizing this it's almost as though you
with your your analysis and your
thinking in your writings you're parting
the curtains and you're seeing behind
the curtains they say here's the
Machinery that's making this work in the
way it does but uh let me ask you is
there a way to hijack these facts to
intentionally destabilize civilization
just as there are ways to fully surf it
and take it into the future to make
things better
it's inherently destabilizing I mean
when you when you realize that the laws
governing our society they are not
Eternal and they are just the the
imagination of people they're our
creation this uh this stabilizes Society
for good and for also for for bad I mean
because it's it's
harder to run a knife's edge that's what
you're really saying that that doesn't
feel comfortable to be there I mean does
the world feel comfortable to you
nowadays yeah yeah I'm more comfortable
in Space by the way the universe is fine
it's Earth the [ __ ] up okay so
um you write about Ai and and Homo Deus
yeah uh
everyone I Know Myself included have a
ever evolving sense of what AI is versus
what it can be or should be where are
you right now on AI hmm
it's a force operating on the stability
of civilization yes I I would say the
most important thing to realize about AI
is that it's the first technology in
human history it's the first tool in
human history that can take power away
from us
because it can make decisions on its own
potentially all previous even inventions
if you think about even nuclear bombs
nuclear bombs to some extent yes we can
destroy ourselves but they Empower
Humanity because the decision what to do
with the nuclear bomb it's always done
by a human I mean who decided to drop
the bomb on Hiroshima it wasn't a bomb
it was uh the President of the U.S
Truman it was that the Chiefs of Staff
the humans deciding now ai is different
from any previous invention in history
because it can make decisions by itself
about its own usage
an autonomous weapon system a killer
robot can decide to kill people can
decide maybe to start a war without
having to depend on human authorization
and it can also increasingly make
decisions about us and this is no longer
science fiction increasingly if you
apply to a bank to get a loan if you
apply to some company to get a job
increasingly it's an AI that decides
whether to give you the loan whether to
give you the job or not and this will
and we'll just you know that the first
tiny baby steps of AI we haven't seen
anything yet so for many people that
sounds scary but it is authentic AI wait
if it's authentic AI then it is whatever
decision you would have made as a banker
except it's a better decision than you
would have made a more accurate a more
precise a more authentic I think that
the worry factor is if AI runs off on
its own I guess right rather than just
doing what we do but better I mean the
question is what is better I mean we
already know I mean it's just been a few
years and we already know that AI can be
terribly biased people thought in the
dawn of the AI age that AI at least will
not suffer from racism from
anti-Semitism from homophobia right so
it just means it's not Theory it's
artificial stupidity not artificial
intelligence exactly so the early
versions are not yet AI they're a sub I
right so no so I I get that but I mean
it's not I mean
you can improve it of course like you
can try and improve humans but there is
no guarantee there
you have no guarantee that the next
Generations of AI would be better and
not worse I would hope that AI Bankers
in 2007 would have known to not give
loans to people who thought they could
then pay and and and then the whole
economy wouldn't have collapsed because
the artificial intelligence is smarter
than the bankers but let me give you why
can't anybody think about the good side
of this there is a lot of there are a
lot of good things it can do otherwise
there will be no temptation and I'm not
against developing and using AI
I think that we need to do it we just
need to do it very very carefully
because it's it's a game changer it's
not just that it's it's able to
potentially uh make decisions about us
it also threatens and this is something
that really scares me it threatens to
completely annihilate human privacy
in a way which was Unthinkable before
which makes us completely kind of
transparent independent I mean we're
kind of already there and we want we're
on route to that I mean if the if the
KGB of the 1960s had access to the to
the surveillance we have today in the
United States they would
I mean we we you know I I grew up here
in the United States and I remembered in
the 1960s and 70s we're free and we
don't we don't you know we we
distinguished ourselves by how much our
government did not try to invade our
privacy yes and and now there's they
know everything about you at all times
and that's the scary thing I mean
throughout history you had
people organizations like the KGB who
wanted to know everything about
everybody but they just couldn't on a
technical level I mean there are 200
million Soviet citizens in that 1960s
the KGB doesn't have 200 million agents
to follow everybody around and even if
the KGB had all these agents the big
problem is analysis every day you get
200 million reports on what each Soviet
citizen did who is going to analyze that
and make sense of the information it's
the first tandem challenge of excess
information right yes
excess data when does data become
information and information become
knowledge exactly and now the problem is
is on the way to being solved and that's
very dangerous because you don't need
200 million agents you carry the people
carry the agents on them it's the
smartphones I mean you pay they do it
willingly yeah you take it everywhere
kgbh didn't usually you paid a thousand
dollars to give them your fingerprint
your fate your Biometrics everything
everything and also the the problem of
analysis is solved you don't need human
analysts to go over all this mountain of
data you have ai you have machine
learning okay you value you're bumming
me out here okay I just want you to know
this scenario and it's real I mean you
look at countries like China like North
Korea I look at what's happening in
Israel in the occupied territories and
it's no longer science fiction
I mean there are governments which are
actually building these total
surveillance regimes but everybody is
being monitored all the time
and uh AI is making that possible
and the the decisions that then the
system takes about people they are not
necessarily in the best interests of
these people now I'm not I'm not saying
it's inevitable we can use AI to do good
things in in medicine in economics in
many fields but we have to be aware of
the immense dangers because we are
playing here with a completely new
entity that nothing like that ever
existed an existential threat that's
right that's right
so you've out let me drag you into my
part of my world here how is your
thinking influenced by the knowledge
that in this same society and
civilization exists people who are
engaged in rampant science denial or
rampant misinformation or disinformation
especially via channels on the internet
um how does that plug in to your
thinking about the past present and
future of civilization
but if things are bad in in physics and
biology they're even worse in history
it was always like that I mean history
usually was so important politically
that it was never left to the historians
and most people they were kind of
flooded with just disinformation about
the history of of the nation of humanity
so it's not a new phenomenon this and as
as we just said a few minutes ago for
many years it was the same is with
astrophysics
that uh it's it's dangerous for the
Viewpoint of the church or of the Kings
to allow people to do uh uh a science
scientific research on certain subjects
because it could undermine their power
and this problem of this information
it's
we see throughout human history
again because so we're not so we're not
it's not uniquely bad is what you're
saying that that's curiously a good fact
um but you don't see it getting worse or
or be in a position to I don't know
needlessly destabilize Society I think
about things like the witch hunts in the
Middle Ages or in the early modern
period so you don't have any Facebook or
Twitter or anything like that
uh with much more basic communication
technology you have somebody coming and
saying that the the old lady on the edge
of the village she's actually a
dangerous witch in communion with Satan
and she's default why there has been a
hail storm that destroys people people's
crops and within a few hours you have a
mob of villagers with pitchforks who are
burning this poor old lady to death and
this is you know fake news and
conspiracy theories and disinformation
the whole thing the whole thing so we
should be glad that medieval humans
didn't have the internet because it
would have been much worse is that what
you're saying yeah I mean what's what's
really scary is is undermining the basic
trust in institutions
yeah because institutions are what is
holding Human Society together
uh the thing with institutions is that
they are brittle as we spoke in in the
beginning of our conversation
uh and also it's difficult to build
trust in them because they are these
kind of it's it's much easier to trust
an individual
one of the reasons why you see the rise
of these uh dictators and strongmen
today all over the world
uh it's because by the way I I
hypothesized that it was because
anyone with active memory of the rise of
fascism that led into the second world
war is no longer alive and so people are
thinking hey this is a good idea let's
let's keep an elected leader head for
life and and are they reading history or
do you surely have maybe another
explanation for it but that was my
simplest accounting for this rise of
sort of a dictator uh elected officials
I I completely agree with you that it's
kind of um you know fascism serve as a
kind of inoculation as a vaccination
against this danger and it's now the
effect is is decreasing because most of
the people who experienced it firsthand
are no longer among us
so again people think hey maybe it's a
good idea but the reason that even 100
years ago or today that people are
attracted to that kind of system is
because something very deep in our
Humanity we find it easy
to connect to trust an individual human
being much more than we find that then
to trust an institution that's a whole
psychological thing going on there yeah
yeah yeah I mean to to kind of trust
something abstract like Congress
compared to a charismatic leader there's
no contest absolutely
no contest and I mean here we had
remember the Jonestown
Massacre uh uh when was that from the
70s uh you know Congress could never
tell people Everyone kill yourself today
[ __ ] you no but a charismatic leader has
that power over us that can't be good
uh no but it's very human it's very
human that's no no well yeah but is that
your excuse I mean come on what is
civilization but the attempt to have us
behave in some way that transcends our
basal urges that's what civilization is
isn't it yes and it's very difficult
sometimes we fail at it okay again and
again we're kind of fall blank down on
our on our basic human instinct in human
nature even when they are not very good
for us I don't know you think of even
something as simple as food
that why do we kind of indulge on food
which is not good for us uh because in
the Stone Age it made sense I mean if
you find if you're walking around the
Savannah in the Stone Age and you find
something sweet like a tree full of
ripened fruit the most sensible thing to
do is eat as much of it as possible
because it's rare and if you eat just
one fig and go away and think okay I'll
come back tomorrow I eat another one you
come back everything is gone everything
now you you first fast forward to today
you open your refrigerator you see a
nice chocolate cake you see hey I have
to eat as much as possible before the
balloons get it and this is your kind of
stone age with the the the Deep part of
your mind of your body doesn't know that
we are living in a modern civilization
for the deepest part of our mind we are
still in the savannah and it's a
constant struggle
to uh bridge this gap between where we
came from and the kind of reality that
we are inhabiting right now
so in a few minutes we have left tell me
about sapienship what is that hmm it's a
social impact company that my husband
and I have established a few years ago
but its aim is not to make money the aim
is to change the conversation
to change the global conversation and
focus the attention of people on the
most important challenges that humanity
is facing right now
so it's things from uh you know the
ecological Danger
to the rise of disruptive Technologies
like artificial intelligence
and how about what's the future of war
in this
the future of law depends on us I mean
it's not deterministic the last few
decades have been the most peaceful era
in human history yes they have been even
though there's localized violence and
things absolutely I come from people
don't step back I did the math on this
between 1939 and 1945
1 000 people were killed per hour in the
service of the second world war for
every hour over those six years and and
so and people say today oh it's violence
in this it's like have you really looked
back at this when 50 million people died
and add that to the first world war so
I'm I'm all with you here maybe there's
something good we're doing and we should
find out what that is and do more of it
the fact that we haven't had a World War
in 70 years yeah there have been again
there have been violence I come from the
Middle East I know this perfectly well
but less than in any previous time in
history and the pla the best place to
see it actually is in the in the
government budgets that for most of
History the number one item on every
budget is the military
like defense the the Army the Navy more
than 50 of of the budget of every King
and Emperor goes to that in the last few
years last few decades it has been on
average just six percent all over the
world we take the whole world together
it's just about six percent of
government budget this is what enabled
the uh resources the growth Health
economic growth economic growth Public
Health Care education welfare this is
what made it possible now if we go back
to this uh if because of of the Russian
invasion of Ukraine it's because of the
uh disintegration of the global order if
we regress if we regress yeah this means
that the money that should go to
teachers and nurses and schools would
instead go to tanks and missiles that
everybody would feel it not just people
in Ukraine or people in the Middle East
even in them uh in in all the other
regions of the world people will be hit
uh immediately directly this is a huge
danger the other thing is if we go back
to an Era of War it means we have no
chance of dealing with climate change we
have no chance of regulating dangerous
Technologies like artificial
intelligence
I mean how can you reach and there's a
complete distraction yes yeah yeah
completely completely so how do you so
how do you how do you get up out of bed
in the morning
let me let me ask that more in a
positive way okay um do you see any
contemporary science developments that
uh that give you hope for the future
science technology that sort of thing
it's not just the science it's it's
ultimately the people who are making the
decisions one good thing that I see is
despite uh the impression that there is
that science is under attack that is all
these conspiracy theories and fake news
and so forth I mean there is more trust
in science than in any previous time in
history
I looked at the covet pandemic for
instance and you can you compare kovid
to what happened during the Black Death
it's a completely different situation
yes you had all the anti-vaxxers and all
the conspiracy theories about covid but
ultimately almost all the governments in
the world that relied on science I even
you even see the pope telling people
don't come to church why because the
doctors said so and right plus they
stopped sharing in a Catholic mass you
share the in a traditional Cafe Mass you
share the Chalice with the wine in it
and everyone drinks from the same yeah
so they said wait let's pull back on
this one you know and they did make
mid-course corrections to the rituals
yeah and which is admirable I I find it
at the very good sign I mean I mean with
all the differences you see that also
the Mula is in Iran and the rabbis in
Israel and the Catholic priests they
most of them at the time of the pandemic
they accepted the authority of Science
and when the scientists said it's a bad
idea to gather thousands of people
together in church or synagogue to pray
they they went with it so uh we
shouldn't kind of
I think it's very important to
appreciate the progress that has been
made
otherwise you become kind of the fittest
that it's hopeless and you also don't
don't uh don't make the effort to uh
preserve the achievements with that we
already made right because you're blind
to them if you're only focusing on what
was not working because you're right
we've come so far uh even just in the
past hundred years that uh to ignore
what we did right is to deny any efforts
to do more of that going forward
absolutely you can possibly solve many
more of our problems absolutely well
this has been a delight to have you on I
mean we all know your books uh over the
years and it looks like you're you're
still at it
and I keep wondering we need more
problems in the world so you've all can
write another book
I mean there are other things to write
books about science problems
am I thinking about it the wrong way
your publisher would Delight in the fact
fact that I'm thinking about it in that
way I'm sure so thanks for being on Star
Talk and good luck with the your new
children's book uh bring them into the
fold have them thinking about this from
the beginning and that's always a good
sign you can never go wrong by reaching
uh down into that age group because
they're going to be running the world
eventually yeah they're going to inherit
the world that we hand over to them and
I'm a little embarrassed by what we're
hand what we're giving them
um yeah well you know it's our job to do
our best to to give them a better world
and then it's their job in a couple of
years yeah yeah well thank you thank you
for being on Star talk thank you so
that's all the time we have uh this has
been my one-on-one conversation with
Yuval Noah Harare
historian extraordinaire on StarTalk
thanks for joining us I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson you're a personal astrophysicist
keep looking up
[Music]